تم صعق مدير الفرقة واعتقاله
بعد مباراة كرة قدم في المدرسة الثانوية في
ألاباما
وفقًا لبيان صادر عن
إدارة شرطة برمنغهام، تجاهل
مدير فرقة مدرسة جاكسون أولين الثانوية جوني
ميمز طلب الشرطة بوقف
أداء فرقته بعد
فوز الفريق الآخر،
وبدأ الضباط في إخلاء الفرقة
الملعب بعد المباراة ولاحظت أن
فرقتي المدرستين ما زالتا تقدمان أداءً
وفقًا للشرطة، توقفت فرقة الفريق المضيف
عندما سئلت لكن ميمز أصدر تعليمات لفرقته
بمواصلة الأداء.
حاول الضباط احتجاز
مدير الفرقة بسبب السلوك غير المنضبط
عندما اندلعت مشاجرة جسدية
بين مدرسة ميمز.  أفراد
وشرطة قام
الضابط الذي قام بالاعتقال بإخضاع
مدير الفرقة بمسدس الصعق مما أنهى
المواجهة الجسدية بحسب
الشرطة